Thank You Leslie thanks for the
introduction I'd like to thank the
organizers for inviting me here and the
Simon's Institute for the hospitality
it's a great to be here not only at this
workshop but this whole semester so this
is not going to be a counting talk and
in a nutshell will move from the sums of
products entering to the tropical
simmering so in more detail will be
interested in the following question
which discrete optimization problems can
be solved exactly are optimally using a
fundamental algorithmic to name a linear
programming we will not be interested in
individual problems but in classes of
problems and the framework of constraint
satisfaction problems we've heard quite
a bit about this weekend this whole
semester will allow us to do so and the
ultimate goal is to obtain unconditional
characterizations of the prob LP for
discrete optimization problems and by
unconditional I mean characterisations
that do not depend on people's NP or POS
sharpie and so on well this is a
classification workshop is the corollary
of these categorizations we often
obtained some complexity classifications
this is a survey talk say recent work
from last four years or so including
some very recent work and everything
i'll talk about is joint work with the
yuan topper from Paris let me start with
two motivating examples on which
hopefully you'll get used to my notation
and one of them has a nap eat before
this is the advantage of giving a talk
that is not on counting so this is the
st mean cut problem you are given a
graph to special vertices smt and you
want to find an SD card so subset of the
vertices that includes s excludes tea
and minimize the number of edges going
across so one way to formalize this
problem is the in the following way it's
an optimization problem where we have n
variables corresponding to the vertices
of the graph each variable can get one
of the two labels 0 1 and the objective
function is written on the on the slide
so what are these so this term in the
objective function make sure that s gets
assigned 0 so the unary function that
returns 0 if its argument at zero and
infinity otherwise written in a slightly
cryptic way
and similarly 40 again this function
actually ticket assign one and the third
part of the objective function is the
sum over all edges and make sure that
every edge that goes across is counted
and we know a lot about this problem or
bracelet everyone but one particular
feature i want to emphasize you is that
if you write the natural any program
annexation of this problem it's going to
be tight so you can solve this problem
using a natural inner program relaxation
my second example is the vertex cover
problem so you are given a graph and
even to find a cover so that is a subset
of vertices so that every edges Cavett
one of its two end points at least one
of its twenty point is touched and you
want to find a cover of the smallest
size so again consider as an
optimization problem in the following
form and variables corresponding to the
vertices of the graph two labels to be
signed zero means out one means in the
cover and the objective function hey so
the uniforms on all vertices of the
graph count the size of the cover so if
a variable or red X gets label one then
it's counted for so that's the one and
the second part of the objective
function make sure that it's indeed a
cover so it's not allowed to have zero
zero sitting on an H again we don't
quite a lot about this problem but one
particular feature i want to emphasize
it is the fact that if you write the
natural linear program relaxation for
this problem is not going to be tight
it's not very surprising but this is the
motivating question for a for this work
why is the case that linear programming
souls the esteem in cap problem and
doesn't solve the vertex cover problem
apart from the obvious reason and it's
fair to say that we know quite a lot
about these particular linear programs
the vertex cover linear program
relaxation and st mincha so you know I'm
interested in this question in a broader
sense for interesting class of problems
not just these two problems how do we do
it well we'll use the frame ago of
constraint satisfaction problems
so it is a definition and then I'll
comment on it and related to other
definitions so an instance of a valid
constraint satisfaction problem or VC
SPL i tend to call it is the following
so we'll use this useful piece of
notation q bar is all rationals together
with positive infinity and an instance
vfc instance given by n variables x1 to
xn a domain d instead of labels or
values if you like an objective function
that is given explicitly as some say few
terms and each term is a fixed early
function so this notation X contracts
and Adi variables these bold bees are
the scopes the variables say the IT term
in the objective function depends on and
the range of the function is Q Bar
rationals and infinitely goal is to find
an assignment of labels from D to all
the variables that minimizes I objective
function so the example we saw on the
previous slide the vertex cover problem
so the variables are the vertices of the
graph the labels are just 0 1 the
objective function is as we saw before
so it has more of a plasmid of e terms
and in the literature so C ESPYs are hot
topic as as you have as you may have
observed this week for people on a part
of this program a lot of definition of
CSP lot of turbulence is peace people
mean very different things when they
talk about CSP so let me comment on this
definition so in the sort of so called
algebraic approach to csps this is the
standard terminology so csps or decision
problems corresponding to questions I
colon player is there a morphism between
to relational structures it fits in this
framework if you enforce the condition
that the range of all functions is just
0 and infinity there is no optimization
involved and the question is just asking
for the existence of a safe feasible
solution if you enforce the range of all
functions to be 0 1 you get so-called
min csps when you minimize the number of
unsatisfied constraints this will be
interested on an exact syllable this is
the same as saying maximizing number of
satisfied constraints each constraint
could have let white not non-negative
rational number so it corresponds to the
third case but still it's the case that
every function has only two value range
to Bobby codomain the penultimate on the
list is the so-called finite valued CSPs
where the range of every function is the
set of rationals so this includes a lot
of optimization problems and finally the
one i've defined it's called valued or
sometimes general valued to emphasize
the fact that includes the first case as
a special case Valley chess piece where
the range of all functions can be q bar
so there's a lot of recent breakthroughs
and results in the approximation
community select let me comment on their
approach to CSP so they often deal with
maximization problems because well poor
approximation is a big difference of
course between minimization or
maximization for is it for this for the
purpose of this talk there is no
difference because we care about exact
solubility most of the papers actually
deal with the so called boolean domain
where he has just two labels in fact
most of the papers also deal with the 01
body functions only there are very few
results in the approximation coming
their way they can say something where
you allow infinity so when it includes
the crisp CSP our decision CSP as a
special
so often hear the results then to be
stronger but for a smaller framework I
really do want to include see a speed as
a special case because it's an
interesting interesting a framework
capturing so many nice things okay
question so far so question is which VCS
peas also are solved exactly by linear
program annexations so what do I mean by
linear program accessions let me give
you a definition of a linear program
lacks a shin so this is again the the
objective function you want to minimize
and there is an actual way how to write
a linear program excitation so natural
that everyone came up with the same
linear program or oxidation and
independent papers it's called the basic
LP relaxation of the standard or the
natural and so on so what is it so the
intuition is that station that you have
two sets of variables in the LP
relaxation I like all the news and
lambdas and menus are indicated
variables indicating whether the 8th
variable X I gets a sign label a or not
so it's 0 1 and similarly lambdas are
indicated variables for the i'th term in
the objective function being assigned
partial Simon Sigma Sigma's of the
appropriate length
and then the linear program lacks a shin
just relaxes these variables from being
0 1 value to being between 0 and 1 we
think of them as a probability
distributions are well they'd better be
all non-negative they should sum up to 1
in fact they are not all written there
but this implies the other so similar
sum should be written for lambdas but
it's not needed redundant and the
objective function is the expected value
of the original objective function with
respect to these probability
distributions so the only interesting
set of linear inequalities in this LP is
this last one when we say how the news
and lambdas interact so if you take say
the Jade term in the objective function
and you take one variable sitting there
in the scope of that term X I and you
look at the label it can be assigned to
this variable and if you marginalize
onto this pair X I and I which is this
son you get the same value that the MU
sub I of acres aside this is marginal
ization a useful piece of notation is
that if I have a function Phi I do not
buy dumb the domain of Phi the set of
signs that make it finite so sort of
feasible solutions so this part of the
linear program makes you that infeasible
solutions partials can assign seriously
they are never part of a solution
so when that's the linear program lacks
a shin sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't later on I'll show you a result
exactly when it works but if it doesn't
work there's a standard way of making
the new program relaxation better by
throwing in more inequalities one of the
standard ways is this a Shirley Adams
hierarchy usually has just one premiere
I'll tell you in a second way I have to
pay so you can think of K and L being
equal say the case level of the shell
atoms arc is start with the blp and
throw in all linear inequalities that
involve at mesquite variables that's the
idea and as long as you keep k constant
this is still a linear program of
polynomial size and you can add salt
involvement ok this LP relaxation has a
nice description because now i don't
consider muse and lambdas two sets of
variables they'll be all Columbia and
the two parameters have the following
meaning so L the larger one or not
smaller ok it's required that every
subset of say at most l variables has a
term in the objective function so if
there is not such a term in the
objective function of the optimization
problem we care about you can always
throw in one we'd say the constant zero
function so it doesn't change the
complexity of the problem now so the
variables of the linear programming like
station are called lambdas for every
time in the objective function and every
assignment to this channel and again the
lab program looks very similar we think
of these lambdas origin lies the 01
valued indicator variables whether the
item gets assigned Sigma we relax them
to be between 0 and 1 so there'll be non
negative II think of them as both the
distributions the infeasible solutions
get assigned 0 and they should sum up to
1 now the marginalization constraint
previous lead was looking at say the ICM
of the objective function to one
variable now it's slightly more
complicated but not much we marginalize
on two variables of size at most K so
the intuition is that we have this
parameter scannell if you have a
constraint on L variables and a in case
and you look at the subset of variables
in the scope of size at most al sorry
okay then and you marginalize out onto
these variables it's the same body as
you would get for the corresponding LP
relaxation variable on the scale
violence so this notation PLT is just I
say 11 reason why we have two parameters
it allows us to pinstripe a stronger
results than just having one parameter
as I said if you are familiar with the
show items are adjusting of kale can L
be equal okay so this is a relaxation so
if you have a bcs p instance and you
write down it's a shot items relaxation
and if you solve it the optimal value of
the error of the linear program is a
lower bound on the optimum value of the
discrete optimization problem we start
with we are interested in the case when
these inequalities died so when it's
equality we say that the relaxation
works in this case and again the main
question of this work is to answer for
which classes obcs peace is a
dislocation works
when it has stumped was it half past
yeah okay good so
so we won't be able to answer this
question in full generality but will
answer for an interesting and large
fragment of VCs piece in fact in many of
these talks we've heard this week this
is the fragment of csps or Holland or
pcs piece people talk about as the
default one the only one in fact is the
most studied one it's the one when you
naturally parameterize by the set of
cloud functions or relations in your
instance so this notation VCS p of gamma
is where gamma is a finite set of
functions on some fixed finite domain D
which is the set of all instances where
all functions come from gamma
so slightly specializing this question
will be interesting man for which might
constrain languages set of functions
gamma the shower lambs are key works and
we'll be able to answer this question
the main result several if you do
results which you'll see towards the end
of this talk will look like this but
gamma be valued constraint language of
finite size on some fixed finite domain
t arbitrary not boolean or three element
any finite domain D then get my soul by
SI k KL if I don't make some condition
so the condition is going to be out your
break so the next ten minutes explaining
the word that are used in this theorem
but if you saw and raise blood of petrol
at the boot camp he talked about
invariance often when we can identify
some in variants that are preserved by
computational complexity then we can get
some handle on classification and so
these properties I'll talk about these
algebraic properties are of that form
they are invariants okay oh yeah okay
yeah you get some results on the
complexity when so it catered so father
that's a forfeit k let's say a problem
cannot does not have such expression
using
so if you change the K can can you
somehow if the case parameter can you
say something when I problems suddenly
has a good description right so as it
turns out the result is that if sa kale
works for some fixed constant scale it
will work for K equals 2 and 0 equals 3
so it's sort of a collapse of hierarchy
that's I thought you'd partially under
your question right there's gonna be on
slide number 25 or something you know
about it so maybe you can leave any more
questions okay so let's talk about these
algebraic properties that will be using
the statement of the main theorem so the
first one are polymorphisms so
polymorphisms are algebraic properties
that are preserved by decision CHP's and
the idea is very simple the idea is that
if you have em feasible solutions a an
emery polymorphism is an operation that
takes these infeasible solutions and
produces a new feasible solution that's
it
a formal definition so it's an emery
operation so these the domain of the
problem so this F is a polymorphism of a
function Phi if the domain of Pfizer's
notation for the feasible solution
schools under F so in particular if x1
through XM are are feasible solutions
and you apply f to these axis component
wise you get another feasible solution
so here are some examples that hopefully
help to people who haven't seen
polymorphisms before you know it I don't
think there are many people like that
here some projections or sometimes
called dictators are trivial
polymorphisms if you get some projection
is an operation that returns one of its
arguments say the first one so we take
em feasible solutions and your operation
component-wise returns always the first
one well by assumption you returned a
feasible solution these are not very
interesting polymorphisms in fact the
feather and varley's dichotomy
conjecture can be stayed in the way you
are tractable if and only if you have
other types of polymorphisms less
trivial now if a function is finite
valued so Q value there are no
infinities observe that any operation is
a polymorphism because any solution is
feasible I know infinite values and less
trivial example so here's a course
that's a horn clause it has a 1 and
hence at most one nah negated literal
and you can see there's a function
returning zero or infinity so the it
returns infineon only one of the eight
possible tuples and it's easy to check
that actually these these kind of
functions coming from horn clauses have
a binary main operation on 0 1 as a
polymorphism it's one of the reasons why
orange that is actually tractable ok so
these are polymorphisms the algebraic
invariance of decision CSP they are not
good enough for optimization we need
something more general we need weighted
polymorphisms the name changes every
other day sometimes they are called
fractional polymorphism sometimes
weighted polymorphisms I guess yes so
what is the idea the idea is that you
start with polymorphisms and waited
polymorphism is a probability
distribution on polymorphisms so that
the following holds if you look at the
expected value of a solution with
respect to this product distribution
it's not worse because we are minimizing
then the average of the infeasible
solution do you start with
so you need the expected value just
makes the operation on this slide
tighter and slightly nicer so is the
formal definition you start with a
function Phi you look at the set of its
Emory polymorphisms highlighted and a
problems the distribution on this set is
the way to the polymorphism if the
following is true if you take any M
feasible solutions so M assignments that
make the function Phi finite value not
infinity following inequality holds on
the right hand side we have the average
of these M solutions and on the left
hand side we have the expected value so
it is some overall operations f MRE
operations of effandi and the
probability of the distribution times
the value of Phi of F of F applied
component wise again on these infeasible
solutions if you've never seen these
objects before they seem strange but
here's an example at the most of you
should know about so the concept of sub
module is a is a ski in discrete
optimization and one of the definitions
of a submodular function is the
following so a submodular function Phi
defined on 01 to the hour to q bar is
submerge allah before any to our tapas x
and y the following inequality holds
often they are defined equivalently
using intersection union so even has the
role of intersection max s0 love union
and this is a weighted polymorphism of I
which is signs probably half two minute
half to max so this important concept of
some of your defense here is a very
special case
that indicates that these objects are
perhaps interesting
so is the first theorem so last piece of
notation hopefully if you have a gamma
language so it's a set of functions on
some fixed finite sadi we do know by
support of gamma the set of operations
that get assigned non-negative sorry
strictly positive probability in some
weighted polymorphism of gamma so if
gamma will say this set of submodular
functions certainly min and Max would be
in this set but more operations as well
an interesting feature of this object is
that it's a claw so it's closed under
composition functional composition it
contains all projections and one of the
earlier results on this line of work
jointly with the on Toppa from four
years ago is the following if you have a
valid constraint language on any fixed
finite domain t following two are
equivalent come I sold by dlp which
means an any valid constraint
satisfaction problem instance where the
functions in the objective function come
from gamma is solved by blp so the the
blt relaxation is tied if I don't know
if forever m at least two there is an
MRA symmetric operation so operation
that returns the same body if you permit
the arguments in the support of gamma so
well it's fair to say that this
condition despite being this has been a
precise algebraic realization is it's
not even known to be decidable if i give
you language is not clear how to test
for this condition but nevertheless it's
very powerful so i'll give you a one or
two examples is it it looks good this
with omega that's an exists it means
support of gamma is the set of f such
that there yes I said there exists there
exists Omega a weighted polymorpha of
gamma and the gamma assigns a positive
wait to F thank you
so here is an example so a binary
operation operation is called
similarities and think of min or max is
a good example if it's a I'd important
commutative and associative and if you
have a similar to this operation which
is Phi definition of RT to you can build
symmetric operations of arbitrary rities
as you would do with min so this
expression is the same as if you had
binary min you could build em reiman by
by doing this they're the result with
the third one option and so on and
because of this construction and because
of the fact that the support of gamma is
a clone we immediately get as a curler
of the previous result that if you have
a body to constrain language that has a
similar this operation in its support
then nav CSP instance built over this
language is sold by blp wise is useful
well it captures all someone to learning
so this is again the definition of
submodular functions you saw before and
this is the usual definition equivalent
to talking about subsets and
intersection min and union but there are
more general definitions of submerged or
a so their functions in the literature
studied which talk about some much of
someone's your their own lattices not so
this corresponds to the case when the
lattice is distributed but you can study
some of your functional not necessary
distributive lattices you get the same
kind of inequality I just the minimax is
replaced by a median join is this
concept of K sub module a where the
underlying structure is not a lattice
but it's a tree and the two operations
which are called here I actually it's a
star so special case of a tree again
some some binary operations me then join
like is this other notion of three sub
modular where the underlying structure
is a tree and you define appropriate
meet and join and all these functions
are defined in terms of some
inequalities which are weighted
polymorphisms and in the definition i
equal operation that is a semi lattice
operation by the previous corollary all
these problems are solvable exactly in
polynomial time
this is the slave and I'm supposed to
pause and say something about the proof
lifetime okay sometime so he's waited
polymorphisms symmetry greater
polymorphisms are exactly what you want
when you want to show that area a linear
program luxation is tight so if you have
waited polymorphisms these symmetric
okay if you have a symmetric operations
of all artists from two onwards in your
support and if you get an LP solution
that is not tight it's a rational
solution you can make sure that all the
denominators in the fractions RM and
then you apply a merry symmetric well
you apply a way two polymorphs that
involve involves an emery symmetric
operation and because the network is
right away you get a solution that is
not at least as good as the previous one
and that's one of the reasons why it
works the other direction you use a
linear programming your letter and again
the this condition is not known to be
decidable but nevertheless apart from
the generalizations of some already
being tractable as the CRO of this
result you can show other interesting
results so in particular like very much
this one Magnus wahlstrom from London
managed to use this result to design
efficient FPT algorithm
okay so blp solves a lot it's natural to
ask whether it solves everything the
answer is no there are problems in fact
simple problems corresponding to say
permutations that cannot be solved by
blp so you can ask what is there an
interesting class of problems for which
blp solves everything is this concept of
universality Cheney talked a lot in his
dogs and turns out the answer is yes and
and and here's what it is so if you
focus your attention on so-called finite
about your keyboard constraint languages
so no infinity allows these are purely
optimization problems then the result
from a few slides ago can be
strengthened and then for gamma to be
sold by blp you only require to have a
binary symmetric operation in your
support so not symmetric operations of
all artists from two onwards but just
the binary 1 so this is decidable this
is either decidable using linear
programming again can be checked for and
as it turns out for these languages for
cube elite constraint languages these
are the only trucker bookcases so the
result he says that if you have a key
valued constraint language on any fine
item ID either comma admits a binary
symmetric frictional weighted
polymorphism or comma is np-hard in fact
this line the red herring what we
actually show is that if you don't admit
this this object then gamma can express
the mux CAD like function and that one
can not be solved by dlp so in other
words even if P was equal to NP under
the first part of the theorem those
cases are solved by blp and the rest is
not what a physical to NP then you can
solve them in other means but not using
vlp so in some sense this theorem is
independent of a peer's NP so this is
what I was hinting on at the beginning
of the talk but it just happens to be
exactly like muck Scott so you easily
just get a reduction if you care about
this distinction
Oh
as far to say that this is a this is a
result even though it's not the 100-plus
pages it's maybe 37 pages the final
version it it it was some some wagon
there's some list of previously done
cases so most of the previous works were
a case analysis because wasn't quite
clear what to do and but many of them
are very knowledgeable and very
technically results but here the key
idea was to well one of the key ideas
was to use algebraic framework is a way
to polymorphism some invariants that is
preserved by polymorphisms and in fact
also by algorithms which is not
necessarily the same and then I'm right
okay so the second result I want to talk
about is this power of shell items I
reckon not the dlp which is the first
level but higher up this is just the
reminder of the notation for the support
of gamma and so this is the theorem so
looks very similar let gamma be valid
constrain language on arbitrary fun item
id the following three are equivalent so
maybe they're in slightly weird order so
gamma is sold by SI que el for some
fixed scale so there's an existential
quantifier missing if I now live in fact
if it solved by SI 2 3 so say the third
level of Charlie Adam's if we don't care
about the distinction between the two
parameters and this is if and only if
the following condition is true so this
time for every emily's three rather than
leads to there's an an emery operation
in the support of gamma that is weak
near unanimity as bad as director goo
gah rising sequence but it's still
pretty bad so what is it so an operation
is called week and you if all of its
arguments but at most one are the same
then the answer doesn't doesn't doesn't
change and interestingly if I give you a
language gamma its decidable to test
whether whether this condition holds
true if we know how to do it ends
actually very simple
ok
so is it useful so that it's again very
useful you can you can prove
tractability of languages that were
known before using more complicated ones
you can prove tractability of languages
that were not known to be checked over
before for instance it so to give you an
one proof one line proof if you have a
language that has the majority operation
so it's a ternary operation returning
you know what it's a majority in the
support then come I sold by si si two
three what is the proof well this is how
you generate an emery week and your
operation from the from the ternary
money start with just like that just
ignore the a minus the arguments so this
is just what was known before some very
special cases again similar construction
if if you have in the support a
tournament operations what is a
tournament it's an operation that is
conservative and commutative or
symmetric if you like and on a two line
two lines you can argue that it
generates MRA we can use of polarities
and hands SI 2 3 solves again so this is
something on the proof so so the
sufficiency of this condition is what we
did it last year die carb and the key
idea is there to observe that if you
have a if you have a solution to your LP
relaxation you can find a solution where
the support of it is closed under all
polymorphisms and then you do
complementary slackness it's not very
difficult it's maybe two or three pages
but they're surprising i would think the
necessary is the other paper which which
is now submitted and there we use where
we will rely heavily on these strong
results in the in the CSP commune in
particular and as a result
characterizing abounded with by andrei
belousov and also independently by
barton Koscheck
okay and that's where the collapse come
from this collapse that's that it's part
of the result from for decision CSB's ok
so again this is stronger than this is
stronger than bee LP this is the
strongest polynomial size shalom's
relaxation the heads off all bc ESPYs
the answer is no can we find an
interesting class of problems for which
it is a universal good sauce everything
that can be solved it turns out that
there is a class like that and the class
the set of valid constraint languages
that can express and by Express I mean
being an instance VCS p instance over
the language a unary function that is
injective so it's finite value there is
no bar here it's injective so mapping
different values to different domain
values and if you have such a such a
useful unary
then it is the case there's a dichotomy
so I become my silver is a 23 or it's NP
hard in fact again we prove here
something slightly stronger we can show
that what happens you can you can
express or interpret in this sense so
this interpreter I'm not going to evolve
but it's something more general than
being expressible this comes from again
a decision CSP so it's a peep
interpretation in a valued world can
interpret something that s a toothy
cannot solve namely equations so that's
the thing that cannot be sold and once
you have equations and once we have an
injective inner function you can grant
be honest well this seems like a
slightly odd class it's a language where
you say well it's it's a language where
over which you can express these things
aren't any interesting cases turns out
we know of to the first one was
mentioned before and this in three talks
and this is the conservative VCS piece
off so a language gamma it's called
conservative if it contains all zero on
valued functions in particular it
contains an injective enoree function
you can build it and hence you get a
dichotomy for this so but this is not a
new dichotomy this dichotomy was
obtained in fact by vladimir come over
and myself years ago but the interesting
feature of this new proof is well
several firstly the prove is
significantly simpler the contribution
in this paper was the algorithm it was
it wasn't known that that case was
tackled before it was a different
criterion and also the hardness so both
of our rather technical here the
algorithm is very simple natural and the
hardness is it's it's a half a page
proof and it also gives a not stated
here this way but as a corollary of this
theorem you get the tractability
criterion for this diagram is different
than it was before it's there's a
majority operation in the support which
is very simple the previous one was well
asking after the talk if you want to
know
and the second color is the class of
problems known as minimum solution
problems so it is its problems where you
have only relations so I would call them
0 infinity valued functions and the only
thing that allows you to do some
optimization is well guess what
injective unary function so where does
it come from over the boolean domain
these bums are called min ones you know
you have celebrations you want to
satisfy plus minimize the number of body
variables assigned one this is a
generalization to larger domains it
includes as a special case a bounded
bounded linear programs and other
problems and again as the color of the
of the dichotomy from two or three
slides ago if you have a min so language
set of relations plus an injective in
array on any finite domain D either this
language well the bcs p is built from
this language are solvable by SI 2 3 or
this language is np-hard again the
np-hard means can express something that
can be sold by say 23 so even if P was
equal to NP it would not be sold by this
particular algorithm so this problem was
started before and again there were some
special case is known before and again
many of these videos are very
non-trivial but again the key was to use
this algebraic approach to get a
dichotomy for all possible domains some
of these papers like this one actually
also deals with approximately so it's
fair to say they contain also a lot of
other results which we do not generalize
this is just about exact solubility now
are these problem interesting it is you
know just relations with a single
injective unary finite value function
well it turns out that if you relax this
condition if you allow this ok visual
arrays it is the newer mu if the
function is not injective you get OBCs
peace so this condition cannot be
relaxed
otherwise you would get a dichotomy for
all VCS peas and hence for CS peas and
you've just saw the federal rd
congestion you can go and celebrate okay
I'm pretty much done this is my last
slide so what you've seen is a but it's
probably not too surprising to people
who are going to say on these horn
problems because they have similar thing
in order to get a dichotomy for an
interesting class of problems look at
some algorithm they're not that many
algorithms known strong algorithm try to
capture what it can solve in this mr.
gross out p relaxations and then
obtained if possibility I could make for
class of problems where this algorithm
is a universal so everything can be
solved and the one last feature I would
like to emphasize that these invariants
under it or gloat about in this talk
these were polymorphisms and waited boy
amorphous there they were studied before
for a capturing the complexity but also
implied they can also capture the power
of certain algorithms because those are
different things but they do in this
case luckily for us so that's it thank
you very much
so how they always have to relate to say
things like polly main roads which are
many programs the internship program can
be sold by many programs
in more than a few seconds ok let's
you're like a new better so I mean you
look at the whistle surely Adams right
there are rather all right right right
right so so so so I wouldn't want to
claim it a hundred percent but this is
one of our with one of the referees of
all papers said then you actually prove
it for SD piece well we don't know
whether we have but but here's one thing
we can beep interpret equations and its
equations are not only not solvable by
shadows but they are not solved by by SD
PS this is a shannon bex result from
four years ago which was actually a
rediscovery of all the results of the
macro in someone improve complex in the
15 years ago so the only thing you need
to do is to show that all these
reductions we do reserve as DP
solvability but you have to be careful
because the kind of reductions we use
are more general and the ones using the
approximation committee but assuming we
can just look at go through the proof
and check that all the say
interpretation using opt fees and all
these operations we do they do not mess
up as DP solubility the result would be
that for any volleyed constraint
language if you curl about if you care
about exact solubility either you are
sold by the third level of shall atoms
or you are not even solved by the
bilinear levels of lacera hierarchy and
you only look at our piece because we
wanted to get a dichotomy out of it and
and it's not even clear if you have a
non constant level of a linear
programming luxation you know what does
it tell you it's not a polymer tamo guna
straight away but
are there questions
ok let's go